These books go on this ring. How is it discovered and (spoiler alert) how it is destroyed.
While Tolkien created the largest and most consistent fictional universe, he did not mind being
Sometimes imprecise - so if you've finished the story and hate yourself: wait, what can you do?
and where do you see this ring? This is your video.
First the first: The Unique Ring is not the only ring - it is the Lord of the Ring * s *,
after all - and this man is Sauron.
Long before the story began, Sauron disguised himself and visited the elves to work
with his master craftsman Celebrimbor to forge the rings of power. Together they did 16
called the lower rings, then Celebrimbor took Sauron's formula and made three of his own
which ended up being more powerful than the original 16.
Why make rings based on the suggestion of a stranger whose abstract has a lapse of one thousand years?
Because he promised that the rings would fix the elves' biggest problem: this world is running out of energy.
The amount of greatness, genius and magic decreases as the time goes by.
For the elves, magical and immortal creatures, this is bad news. Sauron told them that the rings would keep
what their carriers matter more to them. That's why the ethnic regiments are so great
Compared with the rest of the world, their rings have been preserved.
Unlike what the famous poem implies, the elves made all the rings for themselves with the intention of
give exactly 0 to men and dwarves, from whom they think they are smelly -
that's obviously something was wrong. What brings us again to the Unique Ring to govern them all.
Sauron's main skill is to master the minds of others - that's why
able to control both large armies in part - and secretly created this ring for
Concentrate its power in some way - this formula to build rings, unknown to Celebrimbor,
He also made the carriers of the nineteen most vulnerable rings.
Basically: the Unique Ring increases its attack and the other rings reduce its defense.
Plan A was to control a handful of high level elves. But when the One Ring was put
The basic starting level allowed them to withstand and remove the rings just in time.
Sauron captured Celebrimbor and tortured him until he gave him the 16 lower rings -
But he died before revealing who protected the three most powerful.
So Sauron now had 16 rings to control the mind and had to throw towards plan B: the dwarves.
Sauron handled seven rings in the hands of the dwarves but that was not the case either
rotted well - Dwarves are rudimentary creatures that Sauron found impossible to control.
But the rings were not great help to the dwarves, who loved wealth above all things
reason why the rings caused that their treasures grew sufficient enough to attract dragons that the dwarves ate
and his precious rings.
Finally, in the hands of men, always the corruptible species, the rings worked as expected: Sauron
he controlled his minds. And, as mortals, they valued their lives above all else, rather than the rings
they extended for thousands of years. It lengthened them so long that men turned into invisible spectra.
In any way, this plan of domination does not go unnoticed, there is a great war - Sauron is defeated
and the Single Ring is dissipated, it is lost.
But the Unique Ring is rogue. He has an own mind and wants to return to Sauron,
which brings us back to his powers.
First: the ring seduces everyone (good, almost everyone) with the promise that yes, this small
Ring can be a powerful weapon or a tool to remodel the world, and my mother, you are not you
the best person to use it? Let's defeat the powerful demigod who lives there
to start, do not you think? Hmmm?
That is why the Hobbits are great ring carriers: because they are very happy as things are
They are and do not aspire to greatness. Of course, there is Gollum who started out as a Hobbit,
but if we consider that it has a couple of hundreds of years it is kept quite good.
Put the ring on a table and most men would not be able to finish it
Coffee before going to Mordor to master the world and do it right this time.
It's worth considering that the promises of the Unique Ring are lies - no one could
to overthrow Sauron with him really. The Ring just wants to deceive the carrier to be found
which brings us to ...
Invisibility
What is outside the minds of the characters, is the only tangible power that the ring exposes
the rest - The invisibility seems great, but while you love that troll
Shines like a fanalet in the hidden world, in which they also conceal spectrums with a ring
You can easily see them.
To sum up:
The Unique Ring a) It makes you invisible in the most useless way
b) He is probably full of lies because
c) It is a part of Sauron and works for him.
He is so connected that his destruction eliminates him forever more. But the formula binds
the Unique Ring with the rest. So when it is destroyed, so are the others.
That's why the elves are so serious. The victory over Sauron also means that the rings do not
They will preserve more their reins, and everything will be reduced. These books are the end
of the age of magic and the beginning of the age of men.
Hello Internet, if you like The Lord of the Rings and this one
Graphic material, I have made a pack of wallpaper for every piece of art available in Patreon.
All are available at 4K so you can use them anywhere, from a giant screen up
to your iPhone Click here to go see them.